as if we don't already have enough
anti-Semitism to deal with right now
radical and outrageous right-wing
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green is
comparing having to wear a mask in the
House of Representatives
to the Holocaust uh green was
interviewed by the Christian
broadcasting Network's David Brody on
the real America's Voice TV show yes
that's a real Channel that's a real show
here is what she had to say this woman
is mentally ill you know we can look
back in a time in history where people
were told to wear a gold star and they
were definitely treated like
second-class citizens so much so that
they were put in trains and taken to gas
Chambers in Nazi Germany and this is
exactly the type of abuse that Nancy
Pelosi is talking about well let's talk
about the queen of the House of there
was no pushback at all from the
interviewer David Brody there a mask
mandate from mentally ill Nancy Pelosi
is like Jews being murdered in the
Holocaust according to Marjorie Taylor
green now of course there's no follow-up
from the reporter because CBN isn't
journalism it's merely propaganda and
the guy really isn't a reporter but at
the same time to say nothing is really
not an option this has to be called out
when something
when something for the greater good like
vaccination or wearing a mask during a
pandemic is being compared to the
genocide of the Jewish people you have
to call it out and say this isn't
accurate and anybody who enables it in
this case it was David Brody on the
Christian Broadcasting Network enabling
it also must be called out the Nazis
didn't order the Jews to do things that
kept them safe that wasn't what went on
during the Holocaust rules established
to protect Health are not the same as
the systematic extermination of a people
and of course the greater tragedy is
that this woman was elected to be a
member of Congress it's not even clear
to me that Marjorie Taylor green should
have a driver's license and there's an
entire political movement that believes
she should be one of the 535 Federal
lawmakers 100 Senators 435 in the house
535 total there's a movement that thinks
in a country of 331 million
one of the 535 leading us at the federal
level should be her that
is really really dangerous and this is
what happens when we either look away or
we don't vote or we don't vote in large
enough numbers I got an email from a
viewer who believes he understands how
people like Marjorie Taylor green come
to have a following in the first place
and the way he outlined it was you start
with years and years of fear-mongering
about you know who right years and years
and years of hearing mongering about
Democrats and minorities taking
advantage of welfare programs brown
people coming here illegally and
stealing your jobs and committing crimes
all of that fear-mongering that you know
of you combine it with sensationalist
propaganda news media Fox News oan
Newsmax Christian Broadcasting Network
and then you have underfunded education
parents who don't know anything about
media literacy so they can't teach their
kids so the kids have no place to learn
it and then you direct at the
self-centered sort of upper middle class
middle class suburbanites like green you
direct the propaganda at them absent the
education that they need they become
deranged they become obsessed with
protecting their own status that's being
threatened by you know Democrats
non-existent socialists minorities
immigrants poor people Etc they identify
them as the enemies and then in a
country of 331 million people imagine
this is who ends up getting elected as
one of 435 members of the House one of
535 members of the House and Senate uh
it is a vile and disgusting analogy that
she makes she is a vile woman and I know
that sometimes the term mentally ill is
used in jest or as a slur
but there are more and more members of
Congress referring to Marjorie Taylor
green as sick or mentally ill including
AOC who actually said quote this is a
woman that's deeply unwell and clearly
needs help it seems obvious that that's
the case some people saw what AOC said
and they said oh that's bad AOC is
stigmatizing and making fun of mental
illness I don't see that at all at a
certain point we have to be able to say
this is not just an ignorant person with
disgusting political views these are uh
ignorant political views that have been
weaponized by some kind of mental
illness and you have enough people in
this country who either don't realize
that this is an unwell woman uh or they
don't care I don't know it has to be
okay to propose that there is a mental
illness component when it's so obviously
what's going on but at the same time the
mental illness component doesn't excuse
the political beliefs it's a
double-edged sword calling something
mental illness when it isn't isn't a
good thing to do at the same time
excusing bad acts because the person
seems sick or unwell we also can't be
doing that it is a complicated issue
particularly in a country where many
don't have access to proper Mental
Health Services or diagnostic services
and when it's heavily stigmatized and
when quite frankly I mean listen let uh
I don't know if I'll get in trouble for
saying this
um there are lots of political beliefs
some on the left but overwhelmingly on
the right
that are delusional beliefs in the
literal sense and so when you when you
see that it actually can be difficult to
distinguish just delusional political
beliefs versus someone who is uh
diagnosable I think with Marjorie Taylor
green it's probably both and that is
increasingly what we're hearing from
people who know her and who have been uh
targeted and and by her like Alexandria
ocasio-cortez let me know your thoughts
uh but a disgusting analogy and
comparison there